this rapid game only chess it's a little
bit quicker than usual because I don't
quite have the time to do the 15 plus 3
that I usually do this is 10 minutes
plus training itself is a rapid game
just a bit quicker so that's happened
let's see what happens
playing Nick Lang and we have a modern
defense from 9 f3 g6 he has played with
c5 or taking my center let's see what he
does now
he has to be a little bit wary of me
playing e5 and some kids uh-huh ok here
I will take and we'll try to play on
that weekend d5 square
within grade
and there are some good more sim can
check on some I think I will check
knight c6 Bishop f4 that is down wow
really
I want to say downright unplayable at
457 yeah well King e7 is not the kind of
move you want to play or this one and so
I want to increase the pressure on d6 so
night
Night Moves night a3 to see for 192 mmm
let's do this yeah I take and play 94
Wow okay so um capture it all
yeah I got captured I mean this is I
think already technically lost check we
should be six Queen a 427 takes takes
Knight b6 wins the rook one thing to do
but maybe there are there are other
other moves I can also check first check
first it's also not bad he has to play
we do 71b should be 796 checking of
eight somehow this is hanging on okay
let's check him
it should be six it says something
better than Queen a 427 cakes and Knight
b6 which wins the hook in the corner it
is really it's a full row crowd is not
easily winning my night okay if you win
a fluke that's enough mean black somehow
played this game as if you don't need to
develop pieces and I've set to accept
the million waiting for rapid games are
two thousand two hundred but in this
case it didn't help
yeah now you're thinking it's a bit late
kingi 1784 is immediate made 97 96 mm we
should be 796 mmm and I can take d5 next
we should be six I can take
[Music]
it's easy to attack if you are the only
one with pieces out so he has to take it
Queen f7 mate yes sir go important so
can pre with the caption not now or how
to end this game we should be 5 is
probably the easiest way to do it we
should be 5 9 F 6 95 looks pretty pretty
devastating it says something better
and I just wonder about overlooked
something that is even even easier I
don't see it yeah 95
it doesn't seem to be anything more more
convincing I'm thrown up I'm not
threatening mate now but Queen f7 and
also 94 which would so be quite killing
the rook doesn't play unfortunately I
cannot bring it to the one yeah he what
is he going to do look at Satan in this
case 94
that was my my plan I still feel like
somehow his he's hanging on for too long
here if I move the cream half 96 which
Queen Queen h3 may be threatening Queen
h7 mate and 96 oh and what is going on
down King g8 Bishop s6 also quite
killing
now in the 94 wins like mechanically but
create three looks I look strong in King
g8 Bishop f6 I will get six its
trajectory check check check Windsor
okay um and Queen f7 is made so what a
system of them and made in one so you
cannot move the Queen or any of the
rooks 996 still am so and that should
end
see no more yeah this is the only one
that continues for bit here who takes
still I'm also and now p.m. let's just
check briefly if I have I mean queen h8
and then Luke II one check root D one
wins the Queen I'm just wondering if
root Li one isn't just like mate mate
next move Queen a Jade
cinema okay 25 maybe but it's also made
so this is medium okay
yeah those those things you can do with
a bit more time in the Blitz game Queen
age 8 King e7 would be one check King d7
rook t1 shake is pretty automatic just
win the green and then take care of the
rest
with this is just made Queen d5 Queen a
jade green g89 h7 shaking of seven Queen
f6 mate
it should be the one that prolongs it
the most he doesn't have a single check
cannot coverage any of it
end of game that was a really strangely
played game
so let's could look at this with the
engine but there was really a matter of
opening play so this is a completely
yeah a normal position I mean I don't
love this setup for black but it is it
must be so kind of okay the engine wants
to play Knight f6 and I'm not sure about
them in 90 of 6 maybe I can go if I but
that is something that would have
tempted me like this and then
potentially just push this on and yeah
make black's pawn structure lots of
great again it looks good okay that he
weight slightly high which weakens d5
enormous them
so I don't have to I think digging is a
simple decision Knight takes and now
yeah you can debate that but we should
be five cannot be badly yeah I was
thinking Bishop d7 that because I cannot
take here there is this this thing so
what I wanted to do is I wanted to take
green takes Knight takes pawn takes I
presume and then wasn't sure yeah the
trade is certainly a bit better for
white as the engine here suggests but I
can also just continue this played play
here the the issue is always at this
Bishop is kind of limited by its own
pawns it's not a lot but it's quite
comfortable
yeah knight c6 however I thought was not
playable because of one made one blunder
really okay maybe here we should be five
wasn't the best day we'll see what
happened there
we should air force normal here Bishop
as a young but yeah Miami lady successes
otherwise is gone 93 494 when the 86
yeah this is the disastrous d5 blunder
best movers we should be six there but
we should be 696 us also I mean what
what position is that lecture doesn't
survive this either okay so check this
should be seven yeah okay but this this
I'm fairly certain at iam a full look up
because ninety-seven is going to be
possible so I'm going to rescue the
night okay in the game my head Bishop
resume and this now
it was kind of clear and Bishop takes e5
was winning
I'm not quite yet getting it what does
move does maybe it friends we should be
six and then not visually form I mean
it's kind of academic because this is
also completely crushing graph idea and
now 94 again is the mechanical being
because I just wind this back on f6 and
then I'm two palms up
but cleaner 3 is indeed stronger
threatening made him one best man for
screen c7m itself that is all relative
Andrew t1 was made now this was the the
mentioned simple solution wins the Queen
but looky one threatens made and that 25
as I mentioned during the game was the
way to you have to prolong the game yeah
it was a Ted one-sided again this
opening play really was a bit too yeah a
bit too too chaotic said you have to
invest a little bit more in the first
opening moves otherwise you don't you
don't get a game simply that especially
applies with the black pieces ok guys
thanks for watching